well think about this is the way we
thought about it where is the most
defamation rooted in our society still
what what aspects of society is there's
still a lot of homophobia against Vince
the LGBT community and you look at the
world of sports and we have a long way
to go and so we created the sports media
program to spar start working with media
professionals that cover the sports
world when incidents come up that where
there's either been an active defamation
or there's an opportunity to educate
people through sports media we want to
have that kind of influence the same way
we have the influence in the
entertainment world television shows and
film and so forth so the sports media
program is working without athletes on
the college level some closeted athletes
on the professional level still and
really creating the opportunity to begin
some of those dialogues and then we're
also talking to a professional broadcast
journalists people who are sportscasters
people who are writing stories about the
sports world to see if we can have more
fair accurate and inclusive
representation of LGBT athletes whether
they're on whatever level they're in but
certainly there's a lot of young
athletes who want to be able to compete
maybe someday as professionals certainly
may be in the Olympics and they want to
know if they can be out it's a great
story we got an email not long ago from
a mother who's saying my son is an
amazing high school athlete he's out and
I want him to be able to go to a college
or university where he can be out as an
athlete and be safe where should he go
you know where can where can he look to
this is his sport this is what he wants
to do is coming from a parent which is
just tremendous so we shared some
information with that person connected
them with some people at some
universities that are very supportive of
the LGBT community and someday we'll be
able to tell that that young person's
story when he's very successful as an
athlete